[Applause]
this is insane who designed this lovely
number well this is a collaboration
really because this is a recreation of
one of Carl's original designs for Chloe
when he was creative director Chloe
interpreted his viral interest which was
black and short and we did it in a long
Gala way it is so gorgeous and happy
belated birthday to you young lady thank
you this is my birthday party welcome
yes exactly thank you for for bringing
us the invite to your party I loved your
cheeky post on Instagram
but her birthday is also a time for
reflection so what have you been
reflecting on when it comes to this year
and looking at the past and going into
the future oh my God I mean I just feel
so lucky I feel like this is um just a
wonderful time and I'm working hard and
you know my kids are healthy and I get
to come and have fun with people I
really admire and things are good who
are you looking forward to seeing
tonight oh my gosh is Carl's cat really
here okay we were all hoping that
Chipette would get the invite she
declined she was busier I guess I
understand yeah I understand she's got
better places to okay
[Music]